- Hobbs & Shaw is out,
and as of this taping,
is fresh at 72% with the
critics overall agreeing
that if you know what
you're in for, it delivers.
Is this another case of so bad it's good?
Or is it actually good?
Let's find out.
Hi, everyone, I'm Mark Ellis
and welcome back to the After Show.
This is a spoiler-heavy show,
so if you've not yet seen Hobbs & Shaw,
you have been warned.
And I am thrilled to be
joined by an all-star group
of panelists here today.
First up, she is film
correspondent, Nikki Novak.
- Hi!
- I am so excited.
You're making your debut today.
- First time, yes, I'm very excited.
- That's right, and then
also making his debut,
he's a film critic for The Wrap
and the LA Times, Carlos Aguilar.
How are you, bud?
- Thank you.
Very excited to talk some
fun scenes about this movie.
- Yeah, this is a fun movie to talk about.
And our returning champion
via Skype in Atlanta,
you know her from Pay or Wait,
my buddy Sharronda Williams is here.
How are you, Sharronda?
- I am doing just fantabulous today.
How are you?
- I'm great
because we get to talk about Hobbs & Shaw,
and it's just a big dumb fun
action movie, in my opinion.
So before we actually
get into our first topic,
which we love when y'all
comment and chime in
on each one of our topics,
is this movie fresh or
is this movie rotten?
Carlos, I'm gonna start with you.
Is it fresh or rotten?
- I think it's fresh.
If you know that the
ridiculous amount of madness
you're in for and if you
appreciate the banter
between these two stars, I
think you'll have a good time.
I think that's what makes it fresh.
- My vote is fresh as well, so we got 2-0.
Sharronda, are you
contributing to our freshness?
- Of course, this movie
was absolutely ridiculous.
Of course it's gonna be fresh.
- [Mark] Okay, Nikki, you're the last one.
- I don't know what
you're all talking about
'cause I think it should be
an award season contender.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Saying it's a fun popcorn
movie, what're you saying?
Fresh for me, too.
Thought it was great.
- It is fresh for me, too,
because I love when a
movie advertises itself
like hey, this is what
you're getting into.
- Right.
- So I'm still like
the kid that was mowing everybody's lawns,
saving up money to go to the movies.
This movie sold me on what it was,
and what I got the most out of this movie
was the duo performances of
The Rock and Jason Statham.
I thought they were so much fun together.
I thought they were comedy gold.
The action was great.
So Nikki, I wanna start with you.
- Yeah.
- Did the Statham-Rock
combination live up to the hype for you?
- I think it did, and I think, look,
I don't think they would have a spin-off,
even though they have huge star power,
I think they knew what was gonna work.
And I think we all kind of
knew what was gonna work.
And I mean, I love the two of them,
but what I really loved was
the addition of Vanessa Kirby.
'Cause I kinda felt like it was a trio
through most of the movie.
And I thought she really,
I would never say she outshone them
because they're both huge
stars in their own right,
but for me, to sort of
jump into that universe
and sort of go toe to toe,
and there was a scene in the beginning
where she and The Rock
are sort of going across
the table at each other,
and I was just like, damn.
- [Mark] Yeah, it was fun
watching her have fight scenes
with him, Carlos.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I agree with Nikki.
I think that for the bulk of this movie,
you are following a trio
and it's fun to watch
each one of them, so it's
maybe not a two-star movie.
- Right I mean, I think that
the animosity between them
is really exciting.
Especially, you know, I recall
the scene in the airplane.
So, this kinda of confined space
in which they can really punch each other,
but the tension's there.
And then you add the cameos,
you know, that are kind
of very star heavy,
and it makes for such a
joyful hate-love relationship
between the two of them.
- Yeah, Sharronda.
I would agree with the
panelists here on the couch.
Are you as big a fan of The Rock
and Jason Statham's chemistry as we are?
- Yes, I really love
their chemistry together.
I still just have certain feelings towards
Jason Statham's character
'cause justice for Han.
I just have to say that right there.
It just, it bothers me still.
But outside of that, I think
they have great chemistry.
I could watch an entire two hour movie
of them just insulting
each other back and forth.
- And then, how do you
feel about the fight scene
between The Rock and Vanessa Kirby?
I mean, that was the, because we see her
in the beginning of
the movie and it's fun.
And then you see her go
toe to toe with The Rock
and hold her own and I'm like wow,
she really is delivering.
She's living up to that
Mission Impossible hype.
- Yes, so I agree with Nikki.
I really love what Vanessa Kirby brought
to this film and she really held her own.
And I love how she really
commanded the attention
in the scenes that she's not only fighting
Dwayne Johnson, but also too,
just throughout the entire film,
I just thought she did
a very fantastic job.
- And so then you add Idris
Elba to the mix, Carlos.
And this is a guy who
clearly could've just
mailed in a performance and had
a little bit of fun with it.
I really got into his character,
and I think I responded to it
more than I thought I would.
- Right, I mean, he
goes full mad scientist
kind of type of villain, right?
And I love the fact
that we don't really get
into the specifics of this organization
and the villains and
the madness of it all.
It's just him representing the evil
that's chasing them.
So I think that he just goes for broke
in this performance.
- Yeah, because it's a spoiler review,
I can say this, like, Nikki,
at the end of the movie,
when he's off-loaded, I'm
like, we can save him.
We have time, we can--
- It was emotional.
- [Mark] Yeah, I was like,
no, let him team up with Hobbs
and Shaw for the next movie.
- [Nikki] We may have to save this,
but I see him in the next one
for that very specific reason.
- [Mark] Oh, we like,
go down and do some--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Some archeological dig?
- No, I think so, and I think it would be
a tremendous loss to have this character
just be a one movie kinda
thing because he actually,
what I loved about it
is in a lot of movies,
superhero movies not so much,
but in a lot of action movies,
the villain doesn't necessarily
partake in the action.
Sometimes, they're just sorta
sitting back giving orders
while all the other guys are doing it.
But the fact that he was
this cyber, you know,
Terminator-type person.
And I've seen him in a lot of movies,
but I've never felt the
presence that I felt from him
in this movie.
- Yeah, Carlos,
do you agree with that take?
- Yeah, I mean, also he has
this whole vendetta, you know?
There's like the emotional component
that he's a villain that
has this master plan behind,
but he also hates Jason
Statham's character,
so he goes for him.
- Sharronda, you on the same page?
You wanna see more of our
biogenetically engineered
super villain, Idris Elba?
- Are you kidding me?
Of course I do.
He had so much swag.
The entire film, I was just like,
I know that he is on the bad side,
but if he is, I don't
wanna be right anymore.
He plays a great villain,
even for when I was first
introduced to him in The Wire,
he just always plays a
very charismatic villain.
- All right, so we're having a good time
talking about the movie so far
and we all like the performances.
Here comes the first real
curve ball of the show.
Nikki, I'm gonna start with you.
Does this movie prove, in
sort of an inverse way,
that The Rock is actually better
when he has a costar to play off of?
Because his individual movies,
if you take something like a Skyscraper
or something like San Andreas, Rampage,
it's not quite as high on the Tomato meter
as a Central Intelligence
or some of these other ones
he gets to team up with, like Jumanji.
So do you think that this
is proof that The Rock
needs a costar to have a great film?
- I don't, and I'll tell you why.
I actually thought San
Andreas really worked.
And I think it did really
well at the box office,
and I think it was one of those movies,
one of those so bad, it's good movies,
but where it really was an enjoyable movie
at the end of the day.
You know, Baywatch, not so much,
but that was an ensemble.
So you could argue that was an ensemble.
Zac Efron, those two
together had great chemistry.
I think it's more the storyline
and the few misses that he's had,
unfortunately kind of have been in a row.
So you feel it more than
if there had been a hit
and then a miss and then a hit,
but then he did have Jumanji.
But no, I think, look.
I mean, you look at his following
and what he's really smart about doing
is building his international following.
And I think what he's doing right now
is delivering what he thinks fans want,
and he's said that before.
So I think if he keeps
going down that route
of I'm gonna do these action-type films,
you're gonna have some misses,
especially when you're in
an era where it's so hard
if you're not in a universe,
to establish a one-off.
- Well, sure.
I mean, if I put you in the lineage
of Arnold Schwarzenegger
movies or Stalone movies,
there's a lot of misses,
maybe arguably more misses than hits.
Sharronda, if I drop you
off in a movie theater
and I say, you can go see The Rock
headline a movie by himself
or you get to go see him
costar with one of his
either action or comedy buddies,
which theater are you going into?
- I mean, personally, I'm going
to go into the comedy door.
However, I think it's not fair to say that
he can't command a
movie with just himself.
I do think that it's more of a
understanding what you're
getting yourself into.
I think as an audience,
we tend to take movies
starring himself more seriously
than if we hear Hobbs & Shaw
or Central Intelligence,
I think we expect to have
this fun enjoyable ride.
- Yeah, Carlos, you on the same page?
Would you rather see him team up
in more of a comedic aspect?
- I mean, I think that
definitely works in this one.
The banter between them is really fun,
but he's a superstar.
I feel like there's no doubt that
when you see his name on that
billboard, you wanna see it,
even if it's not Hobbs & Shaw,
even if it's not Rampage or whatnot.
I feel like he commands the
attention of the audience.
And you know, I was at the
premiere for this movie
and there was a sort of like a moment
in which there was an incident with fire
and they had to stop the movie,
and he came out and kinda like
came to calm the audience.
- Was this real fire
or was this like hey--
- It was real fire.
- It was real.
I was there, too.
It was an interesting moment.
- It was real fire.
- Wow.
- And he came out and like
kind of like, you know,
commanded the audience
and you know, made it fun
and kind of brought everyone back to like,
an enjoyable, after the
stressful kind of moment,
he brought it back.
So I think he's just, people love him,
and he could command it by himself.
- He almost made it better.
I almost thought that they
should've video'd that
and just had an intermission
for everybody watching it
across the board and just
insert that 'cause he did.
He upped the ante and
then he sort of like,
nobody else, I think, could do that.
- Yeah, I mean, the guy conquered
the San Andreas Fault earthquake.
I think he's pretty good with
a fire in a movie theater.
So The Rock and Jason Statham
and then Vanessa Kirby as well
are your headliners of the movie,
but I think a lot of people, Carlos,
are responding to the cameos that we had.
We had Ryan Reynolds.
Kevin Hart, I thought, stole
that entire airplane scene.
Did you enjoy the cameos?
Do you think they took
away from the story?
Where are you with that?
- Oh, I love them.
I definitely prefer the
Ryan Reynolds character.
I thought he was incredibly funny.
I like to think that
that's him in real life
really wanting to be The
Rock's best friend, you know?
'Cause it feels just so
earnest and fun and you know,
wild in his kind of antics
to become his friend
that The Rock being such a superstar,
I feel like there may
be many actors out there
that wanna be his best friend
so I thought it was fun.
- Sharronda, I'm watching that scene play
and I'm thinking, this
is exactly what The Rock
and Kevin Hart's social
media feud is like.
And we got to actually watch that factor
into the storyline a
little bit so, I loved it.
- The airplane scene, I
literally yelled out loud.
I screamed when I say
him in the first place.
I love that entire sequence.
And even with Ryan Reynolds.
And what I will say is after
the first set of cameos,
when the second round
came in, I was just like,
mmm, I'm kinda over it.
I was happy with the first one.
I don't know if we needed
to go into the second one.
It made me feel more as though
they're gonna introduce the characters
into this Hobbs & Shaw franchise.
- Yeah, so, I'll give Rob
Delaney a shout out, too,
because he also makes a fun cameo.
Nikki, which of the cameos do
you think enhanced the film?
- Kevin's was my favorite.
I always love Ryan Reynolds,
but I felt like Ryan Reynolds
was doing Ryan Reynolds.
Not that Kevin wasn't, but I felt like
there was a couple moments that Ryan's,
there was a few lines that I was like,
oh, Ryan's like really like,
pushing almost a little bit.
- Him and David Leitch have
that great Deadpool rapport, so.
- Yeah, yeah, I felt that.
But I think that Kevin
Hart was such a surprise.
And I've now seen this movie three times.
And I saw it the first time by myself,
the second time at the premiere,
and the third time with a lot
of Millennial influencers,
so it was three totally
different responses.
But I will say in the premiere,
I'm sure you felt the same thing,
when Kevin's face first
appeared on screen,
the place erupted, totally erupted.
With Ryan, I think 'cause it
was towards the beginning,
it was more like, oh wow,
it was more surprise.
But I think Kevin really.
I actually wanted to see
one more scene with Kevin
in the end.
I wanted him to come in and
save the day in the end.
I wanted him to be the sort of person that
came through with a key thing in the end
that sort of helped them win.
- He could've flown a
helicopter or something
into that last scene--
- Yeah, something.
- In Samoa.
There's one other sort
of maybe kind of cameo
that's at least rumored
that we'll talk about
later on in the show, but right now,
I wanna get to the meat of Hobbs & Shaw,
which is those incredible
action set pieces.
Like I said, David Leitch is
the director here, Carlos,
and you know he knows how to
pull off action very well,
both close hand-to-hand combat
then also like these big, giant, you know,
it's just getting crazier
and crazier every movie.
So, did the action live
up to the hype for you?
- Of course, yeah.
The scenes are so ridiculous.
You have to commit to
this disbelief, right,
that nothing in this world
functions like reality.
They're almost like
superheros at this point,
the kind of stunts they pull.
So that final sequence with
the trucks and the helicopter
in Samoa is just so off the chain that
watching it in a big screen
with a crowd of people
is just such an emotional
experience in a way that
watching it alone, it
probably wouldn't work,
but on a theater with that level of action
is just so much fun.
- [Mark] That poor
helicopter, Nikki, at the end.
I mean, that thing goes through so much.
- [Nikki] By the way, that wasn't CGI.
The Rock actually did that.
(laughing)
- He actually did all that stuff.
He hired the best towers in the business
to get their chains exactly
connected to the truck.
Do you think that this was the best action
that we've seen in a Fast & Furious
or Fast & Furious Presents movie?
- No, I wouldn't say it was the best.
See, for me, it was sort of a two parter.
Some of it felt like the sorta close up,
the slow mos felt very David Leitch.
It felt very Atomic Blonde, or you know,
what he's done in the past.
And then this sort of
big action set pieces
like the helicopter and that
felt very Fast & Furiuos to me.
So they felt like two different things
and very two different elements.
In terms of like the big action,
if it wasn't for the last
helicopter bit and The Rock,
'cause that's what I love
about Fast & Furious.
I want to suspend my disbelief,
and I want to enjoy those moments
that you could never, it's
almost superhero-esque.
- It really is.
- In a way, in a way.
But I felt like David Lietch
did what he does really well
and I love those sort of close up,
and I love the two three-way
fights that we've had
'cause I don't think we've
seen that before in cinema.
And I think Idris really
pulled that off as well.
- So you said something very interesting,
and Sharronda, I wanna
get your take on this.
So, it's kind of like
these blockbuster movies
are becoming more and
more superhero films,
so it's almost like you
can incorporate them
in the MCU seamlessly.
- Right.
- Sharronda, do you like this trend
that it's becoming more
like a Marvel movie
every time you go see one
of these blockbusters,
particularly a Fast & Furious movie,
where they were into street racers.
Back when I was a kid, they
were just living their lives
a quarter mile at a time and
souping up some Honda Civics.
And now, they're literally
stopping genetically engineered
viruses that are perpetrated
by super bad guys.
Are you a fan of this trend
with the Fast & Furious films?
- I definitely am.
I mean, there's been so many movies.
You have to start evolving,
you have to start introducing these new
even more ridiculous and
crazy concepts into the film.
I mean, The Rock literally
jumps out of a building
and like, scales a building down a rope.
Like you should not have a hand,
you shouldn't have an arm.
But it was cool watching him do it.
I love the action in it.
I don't think that it fully
lives up to the absurdity
of the Fast & Furious movies.
I think I've seen better, more crazier,
unrealistic things happen,
but I had a great time watching it.
- Yeah, I don't think we're gonna see
the cars going out of the
airplane again any time soon.
I would not parachute with a car.
Friendly, helpful tip
for all you kids at home.
Carlos, your favorite
action scene in this movie.
Which one did you dig the best?
- I think it's that one by far.
And when I talk about the one in Samoa,
I mean the beginning
with the kind of like,
combat with the old school weapons.
- I love that.
- I think that's
very interesting and sort of like
brings it back down to,
you know, not using guns
and kind of like the man on man.
So, the beginning of that.
And then going into the
trucks and the airplane
and you know, sort of like
this big finale, I think,
just brings it home because
it has a cultural element
as well, which I think
elevates the franchise.
- Yeah, and I like the
final little fist fight
that we had at the waterfall
just because it was,
you know, it was a little on the nose,
but it's like hey, Hobbs and Shaw,
they finally realized
if they work together,
they're gonna be able to,
and that's the only way
they're gonna be able
to defeat this villain.
The only real complaint I've heard
about any of the action is that
it started to drag the
film down a little bit.
Does anybody feel that way
that maybe we could've used
a little less action?
- I actually felt like, I
know the movie's very long
and that's a critique that I've heard,
that it's two hours and 15 minutes.
It could've been shorter.
There wasn't anything I disliked about it.
There wasn't anything
that, other than I think
that sort of opening sequence
before you see them side
by side in the morning
getting their coffee and
their very different ways
of getting ready for work,
there was a sequence where
they both go after like,
where's the virus and
they fight a bad guy,
and you know, The Rock tattoos
the thing on the guy's head.
And I felt like you didn't need that.
I felt that whole
sequence you didn't need.
I think you could've set it up,
almost started the film
off with the side by side
of them getting ready.
I don't think you needed that whole bit
because it didn't really
add anything to the film.
And I feel like the two big
second and third act
set pieces were enough.
- Sharronda, you agree with that?
You think we could've
lost that little breakfast
slash gym montage at the beginning
or what part of the film felt
the most out of place to you?
- I like the intro 'cause
it just establishes
how different they are.
But for me, while watching the film,
I literally thought the movie
ended three different times.
I was like okay, it's about to end.
Lemme get my stuff together.
Then I was like no, there's
like a whole other set piece
that we have to go through.
So for those moments, it did drag for me.
It wasn't necessarily
it had too much action.
It was just a little bit too much going on
from like a storyline.
It felt as though they were
trying to check all of the beats
of what a Fast & Furious movie is.
We have to have family,
we have to have conflict.
And just, I just think
that they had a little bit
too many ideas with Hobbs & Shaw
that could've been left
on the cutting room floor.
- Carlos, do you think we could've trimmed
some of the fat off this movie?
- Maybe a little bit.
I go back to the scene, you
know, the Mexican actress,
Eiza Gonzales, is in the
film for like, one second.
And I feel like, either
they could've chosen to
use her character more
or cut it out entirely
'cause it just feels like
she's just introduced briefly,
very quickly, even though
she's in the poster
and she's kinda like, you know,
being held as part of the movie,
she's very, you know, for
a brief moment in the film.
So either, for me, it was either cut it
or expand that character.
- That's a great point.
She was like the Captain
Phasma of this movie
where it's like, you're
on a lot of the artwork
and then it's like hey,
you showed up and goodbye.
I personally like the breakfast montage
just because that's two
different ways of waking up
than I'm used to.
- No, that's the part I wish they kept in.
I wish that was the
opening scene of the movie,
and cut out the action-y part, yeah.
- Yeah, I'm not doing what The Rock does.
I'm not waking up at
six a.m., first of all.
Like mine would be like 10:30 a.m.
And I'm not going to the gym,
and I'm not making myself a frittata.
I'm just sitting in line at
Starbucks like the rest of us,
so, I have some work to do
before I look like The Rock
or Jason Statham, or decide
to save the world, so.
Our last topic here today is a question
more about the future of Fast & Furious
or Fast & Furious Presents and Sharronda,
I wanna go to you first on this.
Is this the way that you would like to see
the Hobbs and Shaw characters
continue their adventures?
Do you want this to stay
away from the main franchise?
Because there's just little winks and nods
and that's really it.
This really felt like its own film.
- Yeah, I definitely think
that it should stay separate.
And I think that the only
way that they could really
bring this together is to really handle
the whole justice for Han,
yes, I am gonna bring that up again
'cause it's very important to me.
But I do think that it
needs to stay separate.
But I do think that even Hobbs & Shaw
has a lot of spin-off potential.
I wanna see a movie with Helen Mirren
just basically telling her kids like,
what they need to help her steal next.
I think that there are so many characters
that they've introduced
into this franchise
that I want to see it expand.
I want to see more, not only of just them,
but the people that they're
kinda in contact with as well.
- Yeah, Nikki, do you think
that Vin Diesel's
getting a little nervous?
Like we got this whole
other spin-off franchise
that maybe doesn't need to be incorporated
into future Fast & Furious films.
- I think he's just fine.
I think he's doing just fine.
They're keeping things very separate.
They've sort of made their mark here.
What I like about this is
they've gone in many different
directions with this film.
It felt a little Mission Impossible,
it felt a little Fast & Furious,
it felt a little old school buddy cop.
So I feel like they can sort of hone in
on what really worked,
and it can really go in any direction.
And you think about the Fast
franchise, how it evolved,
I'd like to see them go more
over the top with cameos,
more over the top with their relationship.
Even the family stuff with The Rock
I don't think was explored enough.
I think Eiza Gonzales
could even come back.
There's potential, potential for Idris.
So there's a lot of
different ways they can go,
and hopefully they go in the right one.
- Yeah, Carlos, I think
you made the point earlier
that it felt like maybe some
of the individual scenes
felt different than a
normal Fast & Furious movie,
partially because it is
direction David Leitch,
and like you said, your cameos.
He's got Ryan Reynolds, Rob
Delaney pops in from Deadpool 2.
And when you look at this,
is that how you'd like
the films to continue
or do you wanna see them just take this
and the events of this movie
and mash them right into the
next Fast & Furious film?
- I think they're gonna
probably expand this universe
on its own a little bit.
Kinda like what Marvel did
with each of the characters.
And then bring it back together
for an Avengers type of film
with all the Fast & Furious characters
and the ones that they've introduced here.
So I think, to me,
that's probably where the
franchise is going to.
Make a couple more
movies in this franchise.
Maybe develop another one
with another character
and then bring them all together.
- Okay so, you wanna
see them spin this off
a little bit further.
- Right.
- And then maybe have a giant
like, Avengers Infinity War,
Endgame, reuniting of everything.
Sharronda, where do you wanna
see the Hobbs & Shaw franchise
go from here?
- I just want to see it
expand bigger and bigger.
I want to definitely see more women.
I thought they did a very great job
with Vanessa Kirby's character.
Just to see that expand,
and not just be a damsel
in distress situation,
which they didn't do in this movie.
But I do wanna see them
introduce more characters,
and I would love to see
like, this big, you know,
just finale with everyone.
And even with the previous.
Can we get some like, Tokyo Drift people
even to just like, pop back in as well?
I would be very happy to see that, too.
- So, justice for Tokyo Drift now.
Nikki, I'm gonna give you a carte blanche.
We got the Fast & Furious movies,
we have the spin off with Hobbs & Shaw.
Any other franchises that you wanna see
be mixed into this world,
into that cookie batter
as we progress down this
blockbuster combination film route?
- To be mixed in with the Fast
& Furious and Hobbs & Shaw?
- Sure, I'll give you something as easy as
maybe a John Wick,
or something on that order, Expendables.
- Well, you gave me an easy answer.
'Cause I think there were
some Keanu Reeves rumors
that he was gonna be in this film.
I mean, if David Leitch
continues to direct,
there's no reason why he couldn't.
You just gave me my answer, basically.
- Well good, because that also sets up
our next little point here is that
there's a lot of rumors going around
that that voice that
we hear that is helping
control everything and giving
Idris his marching orders
is actually the voice of Charlize Theron
who was Cipher in Fast & Furious 8.
Now, I heard a contradicting report
from somebody who saw a
very early test screening
that in fact that voice
was done by Keanu Reeves.
- That's what I heard, too,
and I really hope, and I hate saying this,
but I did not love the Charlize character.
So I'm hoping it's not her.
I don't know.
It just didn't work for me.
I thought like, I don't know.
She just didn't fit into
the franchise to me,
and the performance just didn't compel me
to wanna see more.
- Okay, so we'll keep her
buried as far as Nikki goes.
Carlos, what do you hope the
fall out is from the voice?
Like what is gonna happen with the voice?
- I mean, I think it
would make sense for it
to be Charlize if they wanna
blend these two franchises,
right, rather than introduce Keanu Reeves,
which do make sense also
'cause of the director.
But if you wanna kind of like a seamless
or at least, you know, claim
that you had a connection
always from the beginning,
it should be Charlize then.
It wouldn't surprise
me if that's the case.
- Okay, Sharronda, we've given
you two great nominations
for where the voice could
go, who is doing the voice.
What is your ideal voice scenario?
- I mean, I'm gonna go for Keanu Reeves
because Charlize, she's very capable.
But they really, if they bring her back,
they really need to give her more to do,
make her a more convincing villain.
- Okay, well, as we close up shop here,
I do need to go around
the horn really quick
and just ask y'all your
favorite Fast & Furious film.
Sharronda, gonna start with you.
You can throw Tokyo
Drift at me if you want.
I have not seen Tokyo Drift.
Think it's the one that
I have not seen yet,
so I apologize in advance.
What is the best Fast & Furious film?
- I mean, for sentimental reasons,
I have to go with Fast & Furious 7.
If I wanna say the one that like,
really brought the whole
franchise back, it would be Five.
- Yeah, absolutely Five.
I'm still going with Fast Five.
I think that was the best of
the little street racing movies
that we knew and these huge
giant world-saving blockbusters.
I liked that that was the
best combo of the two.
Carlos, which way are you going?
- I think I'll go with the first one.
I feel like it was such
a landmark kind of film
in terms of introducing this concept that
who would've thought that 20 years later,
we'll be still talking about it.
So I feel like the first
one set up the groundwork
for a film, for car fans or action fans,
and then developed into something huge,
so I'll go with the first one.
- It all goes back to that first film.
Nikki, I have a buddy who got married,
and in his wedding vows,
included Fast & Furious quotes
from the very first.
And they're still happily
married to this day.
Yes, Corona was served at the reception.
Best Fast & Furious of all time.
You have the last word.
- I'm gonna be really boring.
Five I think sort of
took it in a different,
new and different direction,
the direction that I love,
but 7 was my favorite.
- All right, so we got a
vote for 7, a vote for Five,
and a vote for the original.
And I think we all voted
fresh for Hobbs & Shaw.
It's in theaters now, so
if you have not already
checked it out and you
watched this full review,
go see it and then come back.
Comment right now.
Let us know your thoughts on Hobbs & Shaw.
Was it the best action
you've seen in the franchise?
Do you love The Rock and Statham together?
How 'bout those cameos?
And where do you wanna see
the franchise go from here?
That's gonna do it for us
today on the After Show.
Make sure you subscribe
to The Rotten Tomato's YouTube
channel and hit that bell.
It's gonna give you an alert every time
we have a new After Show for you all.
Thanks to my incredible panelists.
I'm merely Mark Ellis, and
we'll see y'all real soon
here at the After Show.